creo que tenemos un entendimiento
respetable de cómo los músculos se
contraen a un nivel molecular vayamos un
paso atrás ahora y solo entendamos cómo
se ven los músculos por lo menos de
manera estructural o cómo se relacionan
a elementos que asociamos normalmente
como músculos déjame dibujar un bíceps
flexionando pse aquí a alguien
flexionando su bici aquí está el codo y
digamos que su mano está aquí aquí está
el bíceps y se está flexionando creo que
todos hemos visto diagramas de cómo se
ven los músculos por lo menos a un nivel
macro y están conectados a los huesos en
sus extremos déjame dibujar los huesos
no detallaré en donde pero está
conectado en cada extremo por tendones
este de aquí sera
fue eso
justo ahí estará otro
que está conectado también y luego éstos
son tendones los cuales conectan estos
huesos a los músculos este de aquí es un
entendemos la idea general el bícep está
conectado a todos los huesos cuando se
contrae mueve alguna parte de nuestro
sistema esquelético así que estamos de
hecho concentrados en músculos
l
los esqueléticos los otros tipos son
músculos lisos y músculos cardiacos los
músculos cardíacos están como podrías
imaginar en nuestro corazón y los
músculos lisos son más involuntarios son
músculos de movimientos lentos aquellos
como nuestro tracto digestivo y haré un
vídeo de estos en el futuro pero la
mayor parte del tiempo cuando la gente
dice músculos los asociamos con mus
esqueléticos que mueven nuestro sistema
esquelético nos permiten correr y
levantar peso y hablar y morder cosas
esto es lo que normalmente asociamos con
la palabra músculo entremos un poco más
en detalles aquí si fuera a tomar una
sección transversal de este bíceps si
fuera a tomar una sección transversal de
este músculo aquí déjame dibujarlo más
grande
esta es la sección transversal
elvis o más bien el músculo dejaré de
servicio porque quiero hacerlo general
representar una sección transversal de
él
esta es la sección transversal
es donde hice el corte y luego se ve
algo así este es el interior de este
músculo de aquí
ahora mencioné que aquí atrás teníamos
nuestro tendón tenemos nuestro
son
y luego de hecho hay una cubierta no hay
una estricta demarcación o línea
divisora entre el tendón y la cubierta
alrededor del músculo esa cubierta es
llamada
y me dio
es solo tejido conectivo que cubre al
músculo lo protege
reduce fricción entre el músculo y el
hueso en contacto y otro tejido que
pudiera estar en el brazo de la persona
de aquí y luego dentro de este músculo
tenemos tejido conectivo en este lado
déjame hacerlo en otro color
y luego se para
estas pequeñas digamos fibras
tenemos este tejido aquí este es llamado
pero inicio y es también tejido
conectivo adentro del músculo
p
me dio
y luego cada una de estas cosas estás
digamos fibras a las que se para el per
inicio si fuéramos a tomar una de estas
fibras y recorriéramos un poco más de su
longitud si fuéramos a tomar esta de
aquí
y si la halláramos de hecho déjame hacer
eso aquí si jalamos está justo así de
tal manera que tengas alperi misión
rodeando la
cierto todo esto es el per inicio y es
sólo una palabra elegante para tejido
conectivo hay más elementos ahí puedes
tener nervios y puedes tener capilares
todo tipo de elementos porque al fin y
al cabo va a ser necesario hacerle
llegar sangre y señales neuronales a tus
músculos así que no es sólo tejido
conectivo también hay otros elementos
que necesitan poder llegar a tus células
musculares cada una de estas
creo que las podrías llamar sus fibras
estas son sus fibras bastante grandes
del músculo esto es llamado
o no
el tejido conectivo adentro del
fascículo es llamado en domicio una vez
más más tejidos conectivos tienen
capilares en ellos tienen nervios en
ellos todos esos elementos que tienen
que eventualmente estar en contacto con
las células del músculo estamos adentro
de un solo músculo todo este tejido
conectivo es el
i
yo
y cada uno de estos elementos que están
en el endo misión es una célula muscular
esta es una célula muscular la haré en
morado
esto de aquí puedo sacarlo un poco si
saco esto esto es una
lula
esto es a lo que queremos llegar pero
veremos más detalles dentro de la célula
muscular para ver y entender cómo los
filamentos de miosina y actina quedan
adentro de esa célula muscular esto de
aquí es una fibra muscular o mío si tú
los dos prefijos que verás mucho cuando
tratas con músculos son mío el cual
puedes imaginar que se refiere a
músculo
y también verás el prefijo zarco como
sarko lema o retículo arco plasmático tú
también verás el prefijo
zarco y este significa carne un ejemplo
sería sarcófago o puedes pensar en otras
palabras que empiezan con zarco zarco es
carne el músculo es carne y mío es
músculo esto es mi osito
esta es una célula muscular y entonces
hagamos un acercamiento a la célula
muscular déjame dibujarla mucho más
grande aquí una célula muscular es
llamada mi osito es una fibra porque es
más larga que ancha
déjame dibujar el mío citó así esta es
mi célula muscular
tomaré una sección transversal de la
célula muscular también
este es mi mío sí
todo
y éstas pueden ser relativamente cortas
varios cientos de micrómetros o podrían
ser bastante largas por lo menos
bastante largas en cuanto a estándares
celulares se refiere estamos hablando de
varios centímetros pensando en células
podríamos decir que es una célula
bastante larga
debido a que es muy larga tiene que
tener núcleos múltiples es más para
dibujar los núcleos déjame hacer un
mejor dibujo de él mi osito haré
pequeños bultos en las membranas
externas donde los núcleos puedan caber
en este mi osito recuerda este es solo
una de estas células musculares
individuales y son muy largas por lo que
tienen múltiples núcleos déjame tomar su
sección transversal porque veremos
detalles al interior de esta célula
muscular
dije que tiene múltiples núcleos si
imaginamos su membrana siendo
transparente habría un núcleo por aquí
otro núcleo por acá otro núcleo por aquí
y otro por aquí y la razón por la cual
tiene núcleos múltiples es porque para
distancias largas no tienes que esperar
a que las proteínas pasen por todo el
camino desde este núcleo hasta esta
parte de la célula muscular tu puedes de
hecho tener la información del adn cerca
de donde necesita estar así que tiene
múltiples núcleos lo leyó una vez creo
que eran 30 un número aproximado de
núcleos por milímetro de tejido muscular
es un valor promedio no sé si es el caso
pero los núcleos están en cierta manera
justo debajo de la membrana de la célula
muscular
y recuerdas cómo se le llama del último
vídeo la membrana de la célula muscular
es el
q
más
estos son los
leos
y luego si tomas la sección transversal
de eso hay tubos en el interior llamados
miofibrillas aquí hay un montón de tubos
adentro de la célula déjame poner uno de
ellos afuera así que ya he separado uno
de estos tubos esta es una
yo sí
pero ya
y si fueras a ver esto con un
microscopio verías que tiene pequeñas
estrellas en ella
las estrellas se verán algo así algo así
como esto y habrán unas delgadas como
esas y como éstas y adentro de éstas
miofibrillas es donde encontramos
nuestros filamentos de miosina y actina
hagamos un acercamiento a ésta
miofibrillas seguiremos acercándonos
hasta que lleguemos al nivel molecular
esta miofibrillas que es recuerda está
dentro de la célula muscular adentro del
mío citó el mío sito es una célula
muscular puedes ver a la miofibrillas
como un tubo dentro de la célula
muscular estas son las que hacen la
contracción si fuéramos a hacer un
acercamiento a una miofibrillas verías
se vería algo así y tendrá esas bandas
en ella
y las bandas se verán algo así tendrás
estas bandas cortas así como esta luego
tendrás bandas más anchas así como esta
pequeña obscura estoy dando mi mayor
esfuerzo para dibujarlas claramente y
podría haber una pequeña línea justo ahí
luego lo mismo se repite aquí cada una
de estas unidades de repeticiones
llamadas ar comer o esto es un
pero
y estas unidades de repetición van de
una esta es llamada línea o banda
z
a otra
línea
y toda esta terminología surge cuando la
gente solo veía con un microscopio y
veía estas líneas empezaron a ponerle
nombres y solo para que tengas la otra
terminología hablaremos de cómo esto se
relaciona con la miosina y la actina en
un segundo esta de aquí
es la banda
da
y luego esta distancia de aquí o estas
partes
estas son llamadas
bandas
y hablaremos en unos segundos de como
eso se relaciona a los mecanismos oa las
unidades de las que hablamos o a las
moléculas de las que hablamos en el
último vídeo si fueras a hacer un
acercamiento aquí si vieran los detalles
de estas miofibrillas si fueras a tomar
una sección transversal de estas
miofibrillas lo que encontrarías es
si fueras a cortarlo quizá rebanar lo si
los rebanadas paralelo a la pantalla que
observas verías algo así esta será tu
línea o banda zeta esta es tu
banda
z
y esta es tu banda o línea zeta
siguiente estoy haciendo un acercamiento
en un cerco pero ahora esta es otra
panda
entonces tienes tus filamentos de actina
ahora estamos llegando al nivel
molecular que mencioné tienes tus
filamentos de actina dibujaré algunos se
ven de esta manera
estos
son los filamentos
d
y luego entre los filamentos de actina
tienes tus filamentos de miosina
recuerda los filamentos de miosina
tienen estas dos cabezas en ellos cada
uno tiene dos cabezas así que van a lo
largo de los filamentos de actina solo
dibujaré un par de ellos y luego están
unidos en el centro justo así hablaremos
en un segundo de lo que sucede cuando el
músculo se contrae y podría dibujarlo
otra vez por acá tienes muchas más
cabezas de las que dibujo pero esto solo
te da una idea de lo que está pasando
estas son las proteínas miosina supongo
qué
y todos intervienen como vimos en el
vídeo anterior y luego habrá otra por
aquí
no tengo que dibujar detalladamente
puedes ver inmediatamente que la banda
corresponde con donde tenemos nuestra
miosina aquí está nuestra banda
banda
hay un traslape se traslapan las unas
con las otras
e incluso en estado de descanso pero la
banda y es donde sólo tienes filamentos
de actina no miosina esta es la banda y
luego los filamentos de miosina
permanecen en su lugar por la titina
esta de aquí es la ti
nada
y sucedió tenemos todos estos cuando una
neurona se excita y déjame dibujar el
extremo de una neurona aquí el extremo
de la acción de una neurona justo ahí
es una neurona motora le está diciendo a
este amigo que se contraiga tienes el
potencial de acción el potencial de
acción viaja a lo largo de la membrana
realmente en todas las direcciones y
luego si lo vemos desde esta perspectiva
tienen esos pequeños y trans versos
túbulos de ellos esencialmente van
adentro de la célula y continúan
propagando el potencial de acción éstos
accionan al retículo shark o plástico
para liberar calcio el calcio se enlaza
a la troponina que está unida a estos
filamentos de actina esto quita del
camino a la tropa miosina lo que permite
que ocurra la caminata es decir la
miosina puede empezar a usar atp para
caminar a lo largo de los filamentos de
actina y entonces conforme caminan su
digamos golpe de fuerza empuja a los
filamentos de actina en esta dirección
bueno se podría decir que los filamentos
de actina se mueven en este sentido o
bien que la miosina se desplaza en este
otro
pero en realidad ambos elementos se
mueven uno con respecto al otro estás
jalando en ambos extremos de la cuerda
cierto o sea la miosina se quedará en un
lugar conforme desplaza a los filamentos
de actina acercando los uno al otro y
así es esencialmente como el músculo se
contrae ojalá en este vídeo se haya
conectado la idea completa desde la
amplia perspectiva del músculo
flexionando pse hasta los detalles de lo
que está pasando al nivel molecular que
aprendimos en los últimos vídeos
y puedes imaginar lo que pasa cuando
esto sucede en todas las miopes brillas
dentro del músculo cierto porque el
retículo shark o plástico libera calcio
dentro de todo el citoplasma o mío
plasma porque estamos hablando de
células musculares eso inunda de calcio
a todas estas miofibrillas el calcio
puede entonces unirse a toda la
troponina o por lo menos a bastante de
la troponina en la parte superior de
estos filamentos de actina y luego el
músculo se contrae en su totalidad y
cada fibra muscular o miocito o célula
muscular por su cuenta no tendrá tanto
poder al contraerse entonces si sólo uno
o unos cuantos de ellos se contrae
únicamente tendrás una digamos pequeña
contracción nerviosa
pero si los agrupa con todos los que
están a su alrededor si todos se
contraen juntos entonces eso generará
suficiente fuerza para realizar algo de
trabajo o mover los huesos o levantar
algunas pesas espero hayas encontrado
esto útil